bonjour et bienvenue avec nous sur rt
france alors comment accueillez-vous ces
nouvelles mesures de restriction
bonjour volodine ça fait des années que
nous avons omis tampon qu'il y ait les
moyens d'en donner les moyens pendant
les années voilà ford en difficulté et
on annonce qu'il y ait effectivement une
quarantaine de cas le variant ce sont
des corps et des cas dépistés 1
il n'y a pas de le cas il ya quelques
cas véritablement hospitalisé d'abord la
mesure dans une situation qui est la
conséquence à notre sens c'est notre
travail en tout cas de trente années de
position d'utilité os ou des hôpitaux
elle est la situation dans les hôpitaux
de guadeloupe alors il est très souvent
il prend que nous sommes plus très loin
alors oui oui je vous entends me disais
que s'ouvre un peu nous sommes très
impliqués dans ces shows c'est
absolument faux il ya un condisciple de
la population les soignants aussi ce qui
nous manque ce sont les moyens encore
une fois ça n'a rien à voir avec comme
le vieillissant et d'un virus
cui effectivement mais ce n'est pas le
virus essentiellement dit tu suces et le
manque de prospective le manque de
moyens le manque de prévention n'est pas
sans savoir que ce pays est un pays qui
est aussi doit faire face à ce moment là
même nous avons inclus de tijd et cette
situation est très compliquée pour nous
il n'ya pas que le coville
c'est l'autre situation il ya le camp
d'école qui vous savez qu'il ya eu un
procès dernièrement une compagnie qui
doit certainement non lieu hier nous
avons manifesté plus de 6000 personnes
temps est venu de toutes les
organisations syndicales confondues on
pouvoir m imposer aux dons politiques et
sanitaires au maroc
sauf que nous mettions à plat de
lentilles qui se posent mais toutes ont
malheureusement autour de cette affaire
le coc vide et voilà ce soir ils ont
effectivement pour motion de 2h à 5h du
matin on ne sait pas exactement ce que
ça va donner
et pourtant la populaire se serait
disputée il me dit que c'est de la faute
de la population c'est merci en tout cas
d'avoir été en direct avec nous sur rt
france philippe bélair merci à vous